All right.
Let's get into audience questions for the
week.
Very important, relevant questions that tie
together a lot of the different issues that
we've been discussing.
First one is, hey, David, if the third quarter
numbers really are as good as Donald Trump
predicts, could that rocket trump to reelection
on November 3rd?
So understand the timing.
First quarter is a January, February, March.
The first quarter numbers came out on April
30th as an estimate, and then they were more
fine tuned on May 30th, the second quarter,
April, May, June.
We got estimated second quarter numbers on
July 30th.
And then we will get presumably more accurate
and precise numbers on August 30th.
So that means that for the third quarter,
July, August, September, we will get estimates
of GDP on October 30th.
That is four days before the presidential
election.
So I would not just be thinking it's possible.
I would be thinking it's almost a guarantee
that on October 30th there will be good GDP
numbers.
Why?
Why will they be good?
Well, one, the GDP goes down more than 30
percent.
You have a new significantly lower baseline,
a record low baseline, meaning any increase
is going to seem relatively larger now.
Bear in mind, think about the number one.
If you start at one hundred and you lose 30
percent, you're down at 70.
If you then gain 20 percent, you go back up
to 84.
Down 30 percent.
Up 20 percent.
You started 100.
You go down to 70.
You go back up to 84.
You will hear Trump claim on October 30th.
This is the biggest rise in GDP in American
history.
And it will be true on a percentage basis
because of that new lower base of 70.
So to speak.
But we will still be at 84.
We will still be imagining it's 20 percent
up.
We will still be down 16 percent from where
we were before the second quarter.
So will the economy really be doing great
when we get that announcement?
No.
Will Donald Trump try to take credit for it?
Of course.
And will Donald Trump claim that it is the
best GDP result we have ever had?
Yes.
Now, I am worried about this.
I genuinely am worried about it.
Why?
Because there's a lot of really ignorant people.
There is a lot of easily manipulable or manipulatable.
I don't know if either or both are words people.
And there are also people who really don't
want to vote for Joe Biden.
And they will look for any excuse not to do
it.
And so inevitably, we need to plan for it
on October 30th.
We will have 96 hours before the election
during which we will need to fight the talking
point that no one has ever overseen a bigger
GDP increase in a single quarter than Donald
Trump.
And it will be true.
But, of course, it will not be reflective
of the broader economic situation.
And that is really what we what we all need
to remember.
And listen, this gets me back to polls, says
Biden's up nine.
Margin of error is three point five.
That means it's possible Biden's really only
winning by two.
If Trump swings just one percent of the population
on October 30th by saying, look at this great
GDP victory, that might mean Biden wins the
popular vote by one.
And you can, as we know from 2016, you can
win the popular vote and still lose the Electoral
College.
We've seen that with Hillary Clinton.
We saw it with Al Gore in the year 2000.
We've actually seen it several times.
So we need to be very, very vigilant.
There's going to be we need to plan for it.
Okay.
And in fact, this is where Democrats are just
terrible.
We know this is going to happen on October
30th. Trump will claim that he is fixed everything
and brought us the biggest economic plan a
little better.
You all know.
You know, economic prosperity, all that stuff.
What do we do for those 96 hours to ensure
to ensure that it doesn't work to swing the
election in his favor?
I don't know what the answer is, but it's
going to happen.
And we damn bell damn well better have a plan.